un espace d'accueil entièrement dédiée à
la prévention et à l'information de la
santé sexuelle des femmes martiniquaise
c'est en quelque sorte l'ancien planning
familial il existe six points d'accueil
ils sont entièrement financés par la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
chez budget total de 2 millions 5,1 oui
pour les 630 donc il ya quand même 25
personnes qui travaillent et ses parts à
fort de france
sur l'ensemble de la martinique en
fonctionnant ces deux millions deux et
un investissement de 100 millions
donc soit tu fais 2 min 11 sec en 2016
le seigneur pas reçu plus de 5000
patiente et à vue de cuisson budget a
augmenté de 600 mille euros je pense que
c'est un honnête je suis aps les moyens
ouvert à tout le monde parce qu'il faut
pas oublier quand même que
population diminue il est normalement
lundi
donc nous devons faire l'effort qu'elles
font cette matière pour pouvoir votre
espace visité ce matin par dominique
bussereau la maison départementale des
personnes handicapées au lieu des
solidarités avec un budget de plus de 3
millions d'euros
mais là aussi les dotations d'état ont
diminué et c'est la ctm qui doit
compenser un thème finance à 50 9 % de
chemins de ce budget là pour équilibrer
les dotations de l'état qui ne viennent
plus nous avions au début de la même
pêche donc beaucoup de personnes mis à
disposition qui est retourné donc à
l'état personnel de l'état mais les
peler poste compenser ne sont pas à la
hauteur des besoins
plus généralement la baisse des
dotations de l'état un impact
considérable dans la gestion des enjeux
de la solidarité en martinique
lorsqu'on fait le total de ce que l'état
nous doit des restes a versé par l'état
nous en sommes entre 2005 et 2010 8 à 7
50 millions d'euros que l'état nous doit
donc c'est cette situation c'est la
collectivité qui doit faire un effort
incommensurable pour tenter de répondre
aux besoins des martin casino la ctm
consacre 400 millions d'euros à la
solidarité et à l'action sociale
mais 50 % de ce budget est entièrement
dédié au versement du rsa